what's up guys for many months now
we have been hearing that the next
series of GPUs from Nvidia was going to
be part of volta however more rumors
have emerged and a release date for the
next GPU series from Nvidia is drawing
closer but unfortunately Malta doesn't
seem to be part of invidious consumer
lineup currently it seems that Nvidia is
playing two sets of GPUs for April which
are the name Turing and ampere curing is
thought to be a mining dedicated GPU
from Nvidia designed to lower demand for
miners for gamer oriented GPUs an ampere
seems to be a Pascal refresh that seems
to be a sizeable upgrade from the 10
series if you guys are interested in
Nvidia ampere or curing that make sure
to check out my videos on them nvidia
tearing and ampere sound great and all
but then where's bolt up well a few
months ago we saw the release of the
Tesla V 100 which is part of Volta which
comes in the eye with an astounding 21
billion transistors and 5120 cores well
this is insane
so is the price tag at three thousand
dollars for that price you can build a
1080p is alive build even with the mine
increase so there really is no point in
getting that GPU that GPU was really not
even designed for gaming even though
that it does excel in it it's really
made for AI research and machine
learning and things of that nature as a
result the V 100 doesn't even concern us
gamers so when can we expect consumer
level voltage GPUs well unfortunately I
don't think consumer level Walter
graphics cards are coming up anytime
soon the main reason for this is because
Nvidia really has no reason to release
bolter right now anybody is absolutely
dominating their market right now and
have been for pretty much forever so
they really are in no rush
AMD Vega seemed to bring some
competition to the scene but really what
they consuming more power for the same
performance and it being like
skyrocketing in price after the mining
craze it really wasn't worth it
nvidia effectively cut off all buyers
who are considering the AMD Vega 56 with
her pointless 1070 TI overall nvidia has
nothing to really worry about and as a
result if they can release a refreshed
Pascal series of graphics cards with
respectable performance upgrades and
still keep control of the market then
why wouldn't they just do that they can
save Walter later and use it when they
need it the next potential competition
coming is MD Navi
but that isn't planned to come until the
end of this year or most likely 2019
Nvidia also likes to spaced-out their
generations with a free year in between
for example the 10 series came out in
spring of 2016 an ampere series is it
coming out till spring of 2018 so
there's two years in between as a result
I don't believe that consumer-level
Volta cars will come out to spring of
unless Navi poses a serious threat but
even then in the video wouldn't really
be effective so for now you have Nvidia
ampere and the AMD six of their series
and maybe a few more extreme level
voltage abuse but that's pretty much it
for 2018 that is not necessarily a bad
thing though ampere seems quite
promising and hopefully these cards
along with the Turing will ease the
market demand and pull GPU prices back
to MSRP thus allowing gamers to finally
be able to build their pcs I think
unfortunately that there is going to be
a stock issue with the Empire series so
I recommend that any of you guys were
interested in buying that to pre-order
as soon as possible in order to avoid
paying high prices or waiting many many
months for it well guys molta is going
to be great but Nvidia is probably not
going to give it to us until 2019 or
2020 because I simply have no need to so
what do you guys think about this do you
think that this is a greedy move from
Nvidia for trying to capitalize on their
monopoly or do you think they are
justified in their actions because there
will be more than uh for most if not all
gamers I do read all my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your comments down
below also if you guys are interested in
AMD and avi then make sure to check out
my dedicate
beyond that but that's all I have for
you guys this time if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like on
this video if you guys loved it would
like to see more videos just like this
one let make sure to subscribe and hit
that Bell reification to be notified
whenever I post new video but that's
what I have for you guys this time and
tonight's video
[Music]